gay s'était surtout d'être une vitrine
de façon à ce qu'on puisse finalement
rencontré des personnes qui contribuent
à l'organisation d'événements mais qui
habituellement ne sont pas sous les feux
de la rampe puisque ils sont considérés
plutôt comme étant des prestataires
techniques ou des petites mains donc
c'était vraiment offrir à ces métiers
une belle visibilité
c'est également permettre au public de
découvrir les nouvelles tendances et les
différents acteurs des nouvelles
technologies qui apportent eux par leur
savoir en faire une valeur ajoutée aux
métiers du tourisme d'affaires et
d'événementiel et il s'agissait surtout
de pouvoir également expliqué dans
quelle mesure avoir recours à
l'événementiel et à l'événementiel 3.0
pouvait être un levier de croissance
pour tous les chefs d'entreprises de la
martinique
alors il s'agissait également de tisser
une passerelle entre une certaine façon
de considérer le métier et la façon dont
aujourd'hui ces métiers là vont sans
visage et des 6 5 à 10 ans donc on l'a
vu les nouvelles technologies seront
beaucoup présente sur le salon puisque
elle contribue à avoir plus d'audience
et à avoir une performance plus
importante mais c'est également aussi
une façon de montrer aux jeunes que on
peut être entrepreneur on peut
s'inscrire
dans des pratiques qui sont des
pratiques aujourd'hui peut être
considéré comme étant marginal ou
chronophage ou pas adapté mais qui en
fait cesser ces métiers sont des vraies
perspectives pour des activités en
développement et on le verra sous le
sous le pôle des nouvelles technologies
nous avons environ sept acteurs qui sont
implantées en martinique mais qui
travaillent à l'international avec des
des destinations comme la floride où
l'allemagne ou en europe depuis la
martinique donc c'est une façon aussi de
valoriser ces métiers